THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT."
♪
>> Mike: GEECHINGS, WELCOME
TO WASHINGTON.
I'M MIKE EMANUEL IN FOR BRET
BAIER.
STRIVE TO BE WORTHY OF THE
SACK FILES OF THE COUNTRY'S
FALLEN MILITARY HEROES.
ON THIS MEMORIAL DAY THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM ARE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN TRYING
TO REDUCE THE CHANCE IN WAR
IN WHAT COULD BE THE WORLD'S
MOST DANGEROUS NEIGHBORHOOD.
WE HAVE A REPORT FROM THE
KOREAN PENINSULA IN THE
MOMENT.
KEVIN CORKE IS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
GOOD EVENING, KEVIN.
>> GOOD EVENING, MIKE.
SOLEMN DAY FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
SPEECHES, SONGS AND OF
COURSE HEART FELT SALUTES
FOR THE FOLKS WHO PAID THE
ULTIMATE PRICE FOR OUR
COUNTRY IN DEFENDING OUR
FREEDOM.
ALSO A DAY FULL OF NEW
QUESTIONS ABOUT A BREWING
SPY SCANDAL THAT THREATENS
TO OVERRUN THE DOJ AND FBI.
>> WE ARE GATHERED HERE ON
THE SACRED SOIL OF ARLINGTON
NATIONAL CEMETERY TO HONOR
THE LIVES AND DEEDS OF
AMERICA'S GREATEST HEROES.
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO LAID
DOWN THEIR LIVES FOR OUR
FREEDOM.
♪ OH SAY DOES THAT.
>> IN MARKING THE SECOND
MEMORIAL DAY OF HIS
PRESIDENCY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
TODAY CALLED ON ALL
AMERICANS TO NEVER FORGET
THE SACRIFICE OF FALLEN U.S.
SERVICE MEMBERS.
SAYING THEY SHARED A LOVE
MORE DEEP AND MORE PURE THAN
MOST WILL EVER KNOW.
AMONG THE MANY VETERANS IN
THE AUDIENCE TODAY,
94-YEAR-OLD BOB DOLE.
FORMER KANSAS SENATOR WHO
SPENT NEARLY FOUR DECADES IN
CONGRESS AND WOUNDED IN
COMBAT IN WORLD WAR II.
HE RECEIVED A THUNDER RUSS
OVATION GATHERING.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT SPENT
THIS MEMORIAL DAY HONORING
THE MEMORIES OF THE FALLEN
ON HALLOWED GROUND AND
ONLINE HE BEGAN BY FOCUSING
HIS ATTENTION TO A
DISCUSSION ON FOX NEWS ON
SO-CALLED SPY GATE IDEAS
THAT THE FBI PLACED
INFORMANT INTO AND AROUND
THE CAMPAIGN DURING AND
AFTER THE 2016 ELECTION.
ON TWITTER PRESIDENT TRUMP
JONATHAN TURLEY WHO TOLD FOX
THAT THE PRESIDENT DESERVES
SOME ANSWERS.
SAID OF OUSTING AG SALLY
YATES I FIND HER ACTIONS TO
BE REALLY QUITE
UNBELIEVABLE.
AND SAID IF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION PUT THE
OPPOSING CAMPAIGN'S
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE OR
HIS CAMPAIGN UNDER
INVESTIGATION, THAT RAISES
LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS, ADDING
IT GOES TO THE HEART OF OUR
ELECTORAL SYSTEM.
>> WE SHOULD GET EVERYONE
INVOLVED IN.
GET THEM ON THE RECORD AND
GET THAT RECORD TO THE
PUBLIC.
AT SOME POINT WE HAVE TO
COME BACK TOGETHER AS A
COUNTRY.
THIS DIVISION IS GETTING
DEEPER.
IT'S BECAUSE POLITICIANS ON
BOTH SIDES ARE PLAYING GAMES
WITH THESE INVESTIGATIONS.
>> WHILE NEW YORK DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER NOTED
IN A TWEET THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION'S 19
INDICTMENTS AND THREE GUILTY
PLEAS, HE FAILED TO MENTION
THAT THERE HAS BEEN NO
EVIDENCE OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION UNCOVERED BY THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL WHO MAY NOT,
IF THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS
HAVE THEIR WAY, GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO INTERVIEW THE
PRESIDENT IN THE RUSSIA
PROBE.
>> THE REALITY IS, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SIT THEM DOWN IF
THIS IS A TRAP FOR PERJURY.
AND UNTIL WE'RE CONVINCED OF
THAT AND IF THEY DON'T SHOW
US THESE DOCUMENTS, WE ARE
JUST GOING TO HAVE TO SAY
NO.
>> GIULIANI SAYS THE
PRESIDENT INSISTS HE WANTS
TO SIT DOWN WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
IN FACT, HE SAID AS MUCH ON
THE RECORD, MIKE.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT THAT HIS LAWYERS, AT
LEAST FOR NOW, ARE ADVISING
AGAINST IT.